no days off and it shows kylie jenner
takes to instagram to show off her
workout games and update fans on her
postpartum journey since giving birth to
her second child with travis scott in
february uh you are all the support
system and we see that so much with the
new show i have to catch up with
everybody kylie
baby number two
congratulations thank you
kylie shares this boomerang to her
instagram story while in the gym rocking
a brown two-piece workout set captioning
it quote no days off giving us a look
into her fitness routine she also
reveals this snap where she's walking on
the treadmill with the waist trainer in
a moment of transparency she writes
quote four months postpartum i have been
dealing with tons of back and knee pain
this time so it slows down my workouts
but i am on a mission to get strong
again kylie's update comes after she
shared pics in may rocking a bikini
while enjoying a pina colada on vacation
the snapshots came nearly a week after
she revealed she gained 60 pounds during
her second pregnancy alongside a photo
of herself on a treadmill kylie wrote
quote gained 60 pounds again this
pregnancy down 40 pounds just trying to
be healthy and patient walking slash
pilates is my favorite combo and in
march kylie confessed that getting back
into shape after welcoming her son
has been difficult i just want to say
to my postpartum moms that postpartum
has not been easy
it's not been easy it's very hard
it's this experience for me personally
has been a little harder than with my
daughter
it's not easy mentally
physically
spiritually
it's just
crazy and yeah i didn't want to just get
back to life without saying that
now kylie seemingly balanced his mom
life exercise and her career well
recently she took little cutie stormi on
a mommy daughter day to ulta beauty to
check out her kylie cosmetics collection
and when it comes to her and travis's
baby boy we are still waiting to see his
face and learn his name which was
initially revealed as wolfe but the
couple later announced they changed
their minds and in april kylie told e.t
why wolf was never on our list
um
it just was actually something chloe
suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf i just
wasn't him we have some maybe really
strong options but we haven't officially
changed we have some placeholders so
before i officially change it i just
want to be sure you're seeing that
little personality
[Music]